- It's about to get even
more country than this cabin,
up in here, alright?
I've got a friend of
mine, a guy on the line,
that's going to be joining us.
He's super talented singer/songwriter,
who's going to be performing
for us a little later as well.
Thomas Rhett Akins, you there?
What's up?
- Good.
- I like your hat collection, my man.
- Oh, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
All right, Thomas Rhett, how's
quarantine going at home?
I've been seeing your
pictures. They're awesome.
- Yeah, we're making the
best of it, for sure.
We're getting really creative, I guess.
With the girls and trying to
figure out new ways to have fun
and watching a lot of Disney
Plus happening in our house.
- Oh my gosh. That's the only two things
my kids say. Disney Plus.
Like, I've had to take their iPad away.
I know it's like a way to
give them something to do
so you can actually get stuff done, but--
- Yeah.
- Man, they are just going nuts right now.
Are your kids going nuts?
- They're going pretty crazy.
Our kids too, like with the
iPad, like they get on YouTube
and they go down the worm
hole of the kid videos.
- Yep.
- I start looking at them, and I'm like,
what are you even watching?
And I'm like, no more iPad.
This is not gonna work.
- No, I have to take it away.
I'm like, I don't know what
my little girl is watching,
but all the sudden she became
like 16 instead of five.
And she has so much attitude.
But, it is kind of cool
because we're on the road a lot
as musicians, so it's kind
of cool to be like, at home
and kind of forced into this
environment that we don't
generally get to be a part of.
And you all just had a baby, right?
- We did.
- You all got a fresh one out the oven.
- We (laughs) yeah.
She's like, she's a little
over two months old.
Her name is Lennon.
- So pretty.
- And last night she slept from like 11:00
to 7:40 in the morning.
And it was--
- (Kelly whispers) Yes!
- It was absolutely mind blowing.
It was amazing.
- Oh my gosh.
- Probably one of the best
nights of my life, honestly.
- That is, I totally feel that.
It seems like a simple statement,
but that's a glorious victory.
- It's a big deal.
- (Kelly laughs)
- Big deal, for sure.
- That's a big deal.
Well, I saw you posted a photo
of how you handle spit up.
(Dog barks) Oh, sorry, my dog
just barked at my husband.
So apparently he's evil.
- It's okay, our dog--
- No, sorry, he was barking.
But I saw this photo that
you posted and have you just
given up on shirts?
Because like you've got vomit
going down the back of you.
- No, you know what, it's
funny is someone asked me that
the other day.
They go, "Do you ever wear a shirt?"
And when I'm at home, the
answer is not much of the time.
Because I guess when I
work out of the house
and I work out without a shirt on and
then I don't shower until, you
know, seven o'clock at night.
Just kind of leave the shirt off.
- Yeah.
- Especially when I'm holding
the baby, I mean there's no
point in ruining, you know,
eight shirts during the day.
I think my wife changes about 17 times
just from spit up, so.
- Oh my gosh. I gave up on nice things.
I just own black or white.
I'm just like, whatever.
So I saw a video showing you outdoors,
while you are quarantining.
What were you doing in a tree?
Like I saw this video of you
like trying to swing like Tarzan.
What was the deal with that?
- We just moved into a new house
and we were kind of exploring outside
and my wife noticed this
vine hanging from the tree
and my kids were trying to swing on it
and Lauren was like, I used
to do that when I was little.
She was like let me go try it
and I said "how about you
let me go try it first
just to make sure that it's like stable."
And so I like yanked
on it a couple of times
and it felt fine and
then I like went for it,
and the limb just snapped
in half and I think
I bruised my tailbone and
I'm really embarrassed
that Lauren caught that
on video, but you know,
that's just what we do around here.
- Is your wife there? Is
that who you keep looking at?
- Yeah, she is. You
want to come over here?
- Hey, what's up?
- She was doing the girls' hair.
- Oh, making it pretty?
- Hey.
- Hi. Do your girls ask for braids?
My girl asks for braids all the time.
- Yes, Elsa braids. Elsa and Anna braids,
is what they call them.
- Exactly.
And I keep telling my
girl, like you don't have
that hair yet. Okay?
Like I can do a braid,
but you ain't got that.
That's not happening yet.
So, that's amazing.
Hey, well how are you doing
as a mamma? This is a lot.
- Yeah. Honestly, we're good.
We're going on like 30,
or no, 40 something days
- 40 days.
Quarantine because our kids
had the flu the week before
coronavirus hit, so
- Yeah.
- But my sister and her
husband live close by,
and my best friend lives close
by, and they all were able
to work from home like super
early on, so they were like
we're going to come
quarantine at your house.
So they have been here
- Oh
- I think they said
yesterday it was 34 days.
That they had been here.
- We've had a lot of
help, which has been nice.
And a lot of (mumble).
- I was going to say, that's
incredibly cool because
I was going to say you all
being like, I know you have
already been parents but a baby is a lot,
and especially in this time.
- It's tough.
That's a lot just to get, and
I know that sounds horrible,
but every parent's thinking it.
Sometimes you just need to be alone.
Without them.
- Just to like come back and be fresh
and not hate your life.
- Absolutely.
- We've had lots of extra
sets of hands around.
To hold the baby, while
somebody cooks or entertain
the toddlers, or you know.
- That's so cool.
- It's been fun. Lots of games.
- Well, that's kind of cool.
You've got your own quarantine community.
I like that.
- Yeah.
- So, you studied to be
a nurse, right, Lauren?
And I heard you celebrated
Thomas' 30th birthday
by surprising some nursing students.
That was cool.
- We did. It was sweet.
It was fun.
- How did that come about?
- I'd stayed connected
with the nursing school.
I went to the University
of Tennessee in Knoxville.
And I have just stayed really
close with that community
and they were like would you
all mind calling in and just
encouraging some of the
students and, I mean,
I can't imagine, my brother
is actually a senior this year
at UT and I just can't imagine
that being in college and
especially in high school,
there's so many like last things
that so many kids
- Yeah, that are kind of
getting ripped away from people. Yeah.
- But I do think people are
doing a really good job at just
finding creative ways to celebrate.
It will definitely be for
all these students such an
unforgettable senior year.
- Yeah, for sure.
- It was cool to get to
at least try to encourage.
We have no idea
what they are feeling, but I'm sure,
there's so many unknowns.
- It was nice because it
was a thoughtful thing.
And I think that the, for
everybody like that putting their
life on the line right now for us.
That's a lot to ask of a human.
- It is.
- And a heart.
I love your love story.
Would you tell it for us?
Tell everyone how you met.
And where you were like,
he's the one, Lauren.
- It was one summer night.
- No but you all were really young.
- We have known each other
for a really long time.
- Like how long? Tell
everyone how long you all have
known each other.
- We've known each other-
- First grade.
- First grade
- Technically
- We started going to school together.
I don't really know how
much you can know somebody
in first grade.
- Yeah, it was middle school
when we like really got
to be close, hung out a whole lot more,
and church camp was kind of
the start of the friendship
in middle school, but then it just--
- Watch out for church camp.
That's where people be making out.
- That's right.
- Finding the Lord and a girlfriend.
- Yeah, there's a picture of
us somewhere, of me and Lauren
at church camp. I think we
were fifth grade, sixth grade.
But I was like a foot
shorter than Lauren was.
- Yeah.
- And I dyed my hair black
because I was in this like punk
rock band and, you know, I
just was obsessed with her
and I'm sure she looked at
me like "yeah, probably not."
But we became really good
friends that year and actually
dated a little bit when we were 16.
- It wasn't good.
- I was a needy boyfriend.
If that makes any sense.
- Well, you're also 16.
So you're still like in puberty too.
- Exactly. Figuring it out.
- Did everybody tell you it was not
gonna work out because that's
- Absolutely.
- That's weird that it did. It's awesome.
- Yeah, so we broke up but still remained
really good friends and
both dated other people from
us five or six years.
Through all of that time, we
went on double dates together
with other people that we were dating.
- He would come stay with me
and my roommates in college.
Because he went to a school
in Nashville and we were
in Knoxville which is
roughly a three hour drive.
So on the weekends, he would
come up and go to games
and stay with us.
And I think a couple of times
he stayed with my boyfriend,
we just-
- (Laughing) I love this.
- Yeah. We are a very tight
knit circle we run with so.
- Lauren, I also wanted to
bring this up because you
just wrote a book called
"Live in Love" about your life
and family.
So what made you want to write it?
Because that's a lot to
let people in your life.
- Yep. It is.
You know, I think marrying
him was a pretty big leap
of faith as far as knowing
which direction he was trying
to go with his career.
His whole world is super out
of my box and so writing a book
was not something that I ever
had like on my dream checklist
but I did I wanted to share my story.
I was encouraged to share my story.
I didn't think I would
ever would in this capacity
but I actually went in to my
agency's office just to talk
through possibly writing a
children's book because we were
in the process of adopting Willa Gray.
And they were like it
would be cool if you wrote
a children's book that
had to do with Africa,
African themed,
so we kind of went in talking
about that and she was like
well tell me a little about yourself.
As I was like talking through
how I was raised and some
of the stories throughout my
life and kind of what had led
me to where I was now, I'm
pretty sure she had cried
like three times throughout
me telling my story.
I was like is this normal?
- It moved her.
- And she was like wiping her eyes
and she was like that's it.
Like you have to tell that story first.
We'll get to children's books later.
But I was like, really?
And our manager, who is one
of our very best friends,
she was like, Lauren, I've
been telling you for awhile
you need to be writing this stuff down.
There's so many good stories in your life.
So that's really what started it.
It turned into a full-on book.
- It's about your life and
kind of how you've handled it
and navigated it, right?
- Right.
- Living in love.
- Marriage and our kids,
adoption, biological.
How I was raised.
Kind of what our life is like now.
It was a really therapeutic process,
going back through
all of that.
- For both of us. Sure.
- I'll bet.
- But it was good. It's scary.
I would be lying if I
told you I wasn't anxious
and nervous about this coming
out, just because it is
really personal.
It's really honest.
And this is so not my comfort
zone, just being in this world
and being super vulnerable to people
that you may never meet.
But it's been a really cool,
I've been surprised at how cool
the process has been, and how
excited I do feel, although
the nerves are still definitely there.
- Connecting to people through
your book is such a powerful
thing because a lot of
people go through things
with blended families and
everybody's from a different kind
of place, and that can be very hard.
- For sure.
- Why did you adopt first?
You adopted first, right?
- We did. I had always talked
about adopting my whole life.
My mom is actually adopted.
I just thought it was really
cool, so we talked about it
off and on but it wasn't
something that we had sat down
and had a like a full-on
adoption conversation.
And then I was in Uganda in 2016
- Yeah.
- And I had a picture of
one of the babies there.
And I had shared it on social media
and when I finally got to
FaceTime him that night
I was telling him her story
and I was like, "Babe, we know
so many people who are
trying to adopt right now
and this little girl
needs a forever home."
I was like so moved I mean
the second I touched her
it was like electric and
I was like "oh, my word.
This little girl has just taken my heart."
And I was like, "Honey, we have
got to find her her forever
home," like I know that's why
I'm here is to get this girl
to her home.
- Oh, my God. Okay.
You totally Oprah-ed me just now.
I'm like, okay.
I did my own make up and
this is not waterproof.
Like it's so beautiful
because I know that feeling
because the moment you
touch them or hold somebody
it doesn't matter if it's yours or not.
We're a blended family.
This is my purpose.
It's such a powerful thing.
- For sure. For sure.
- So how did that turn
into ya'll adopting?
- When I talked to her
on the phone that night
and she said we needed to
find her a home, I literally,
it was after a concert,
and I was going to bed,
and I was like, "we'll bring her home."
And I don't fully remember even saying it.
It was like such a spiritual
thing for me that it just
came out of my body.
And then literally two weeks
after, we were having home
assessments and talking to
adoption agencies and then
I got to go to Uganda maybe
- October
- Yeah, like six months later.
And then I got to meet her
for the first time and that's
when we really started
the process and we were--
Lauren was there for like a
total of a very long time.
And I was going to Uganda, I
remember I played a show in
Phoenix, Arizona and flew
from Phoenix to Uganda,
stayed for a week, came
back home, played Nashville,
and then came right back to Uganda.
And it was like this
really, really strange time
of like I'm still doing
touring things and Lauren is
in the middle of all of this
and then fast-forward like
three months later we're
pregnant in Uganda.
- (laughing)
- Ugandan toilets
- I remember playing the
Nashville show and I was talking
to her and I was like
"what are you doing?"
And she was like "I'm currently
just yacking in the toilet."
She's like, "what are you doing?"
Well, I'm hanging out with
all of your best friends
in Nashville.
You'll see this in the book.
Like I look like a total jerk.
- No.
- Seventeen million times in the book.
And I probably am a lot of the time.
- You're also doing your job,
like that's how you provide.
- Yeah.
- Provide for your family.
And then I just got to say
before I move on to something
else I love about you all.
It's a really beautiful thing
that I think I believe that
things in life are supposed
to happen when they happen.
Like regardless if it's good or not.
It's just how it is and you handle it.
And I love how you said
"It was just something
that came out of you."
Because I think that says a
lot about both of your hearts,
it's that you noticed there
was a need for something
and you fulfilled it.
- Yeah.
- And it wasn't a question.
you know, it was like
this just needs to happen.
I think that's a really
beautiful thing and how we should
live our lives.
All right, so Thomas the song
that you're going to do for us
later is called "Be a Light."
It's a great anthem for
the world right now,
like how did this song come about?
I know there's a lot of
artists on it, right?
- Yeah. I actually wrote
this song last year
in a whole different mind
set, like having no clue
that COVID-19 was about to hit the world.
- Yeah.
- So it was going to kind
of be on like our next album
that we're going to start
working on at some point
in the near future, hopefully,
but just when all of this
started happening I called
my label and I was like,
"Hey, I think this song
needs to come out now.
Like I think the world
needs to hear this song."
Because it's a really
encouraging song just about being
a light in a dark place,
and I kind of think that's
kind of the world we're in right now.
So we decided to put it
out and we got Reba on it,
Keith Urban, Chris
Thomlin, and Hillary Scott
are singing on it with me,
which was super special
and a bunch of the proceeds
are going to the Music Cares
COVID Relief Fund, which is really cool.
So whether you stream it on
any platform or YouTube it
or download it that money
will go to help a lot
of the people.
- All right. Well thank you guys so much.
We are going to get to hear
Thomas Rhett sing later
in the show, very excited about that.
The song is called, "Be a Light."
So please go download it now
and also go order Lauren's book.
You can pre-order it right now.
It's called "Live in Love"
or you can get it August 18.
It's a great, great message.
You're going to love it.
You're going to connect to it.